miso poached salmon with asian
vegetables
organization is key in the kitchen take
a couple of minutes before you start
and set yourself up make sure you know
where everything is
stock spatula pan etc it becomes less
stressful but more importantly the end
results
are incredible
[Music]
first off get your pan on whisk
and stock start off with this amazing
fermented
soy bean puree into the pan three nice
tablespoons
gas on now get your fish stock and whisk
into the puree be generous with the
stock
you want this nice light broth
basically you can buy miso paste from
big supermarkets and it works
brilliantly with salmon
poaching the salmon in the miso stuff
gives it a really nice sort of
sweet earthy creamy flavor it's
incredible
bring it up to the i'm gonna infuse the
broth
and make it a little bit more fragrant
kaffir lime leaf is very lemony
inside the miso broth then chopped chili
chili's in and finally sliced ginger
that's simmering beautifully now we're
gonna poach the salmon
poaching means cooking it in liquid but
it's cooked
gently and the secret here is to keep
that salmon skin on
if we took the skin off now the salmon
can actually break up
whilst it's poaching skin side
down just gonna slide that in
under nice the minute that's stopped
starts boiling turn it down let it
simmer
take a little ladle and just every
couple of minutes
pour over that makes sure the top of the
salmon is cooked evenly
and keeps it nice and moist and poaching
is one of the most delicate ways of
cooking so you have to handle it
with care whilst the salmon's poaching
in the miso broth
start preparing your vegetables i'm
using tender stem broccoli
and bak choy i always like to cook
the leaf and the stem separately the
leaf is like sort of spinach
and the stem is so much thicker it's
almost as thick as a stick of celery
so i like to get the stems sliced
just so i've got that nice sort of
christmas place the leaves together
nicely
roll them up nice and tight and then
slice them down now
my salad already the flavor
in that broth has been elevated
now it tastes really fishy got the heat
the chili
spiciness the ginger and the caffeine
lime leaf
take your fish slice and place it very
gently underneath the salmon and push it
down fish slices are
flexible for that reason bend it lift it
up
just touch looking for a springy firm
texture and just
sit there on top a little touch of the
broth over it
it stops it from drying out leave that
to cool down for two minutes
bring the stock back up to the boil
broccoli and
bak choy stems in little taste
it's getting better and better and
better cook
the broccoli and the bok choy stems for
one minute and then add
the tops in turn the salmon into your
hand and
just peel all that skin off the skin
also
helps to keep the salmon nice and moist
then gently flake the salmon
that's the secret behind poaching
everything just stays
so moist wonderful long shards of
pink now just before we serve we're
going to add our mushrooms these are
enoki mushrooms
you can buy these in okie mushrooms in
big supermarkets and good grocers
slice them off i'm going to put half in
and the other half
i'm gonna serve with the salmon toasted
sesame seed oil
put a little drip in there just rub
and you're just lining almost like a
little coat of varnish
start off with your mushrooms and then
my salmon
four nice layers and then finally
the mushrooms top with the vegetables
and then finally a nice ladle
that beautiful really sumptuous
rich stock
lovely and that is an amazing
misu poached salmon soup simplify your
cooking by getting organized and amazing
food will be coming out of your kitchen
every day first prep the veg
chopped spring onions shallots
a clove of garlic and chili to taste
then thinly slice celery
add a bay leaf and thyme veg ready
[Music]
add oil to a pan and fry
[Music]
season then add mussels and stir
mussels one of my favorite shellfish
cheap healthy and delicious
cover and sting for a couple of minutes
as the mussels open
add vermouth an aromatic 45 wine
[Music]
and 150ml of dry white wine
on a high heat reduce the liquid to
create a source
discard any muscles that are still shut
[Music]
then finish with creme fresh and chopped
parsley
[Music]
minimal prep and cooked in less than 10
minutes my muscles with celery and chili
impressive affordable and super speedy
start with the spice coating toast
szechuan peppercorns
and coriander seeds in a hot dry pan to
release their flavours
[Music]
add chili flakes and grind a pestle and
water to make a fiery fine powder
combine with plain flour season and mix
[Music]
add olive oil to a hot pan
coat white bait in the spicy flour mix
then fry
white bait are an oily fish that are
healthy delicious
and cooking minutes
once golden they're done fantastic with
garlic mayonnaise or a simple squeeze of
[Music]
lemon ready in under 10 minutes
chilli and spiced white bait an easy
simple spicy dish
[Music]
first make a spicy paste by crushing
garlic in a pestle and mortar
along with paprika sea salt
and olive oil spoon the paste onto
philips of mackerel
a great inexpensive oily fish that's
really healthy
and leave to marinade when ready to eat
put the mackerel fillets on a baking
tray skin side up
season and roast in a hot oven
next make a tangy potato salad
for the dressing mix dijon mustard white
wine vinegar
olive oil and saffron
[Music]
and whisk until blended boil new
potatoes in salted water
drain and lightly crush add sliced
spring onion
and spoon in the vinaigrette
[Applause]
to serve top the potato salad with the
roasted mackerel
and drizzle with more vinaigrette
a healthy meal that makes the most of
cheap but delicious fish
stunning roasted mackerel with garlic
and paprika
[Music]
i love this recipe why because it turns
this humble ingredient
a can of tuna into something delicious
just open up and drain
the tuna into a sieve just lightly flake
that
don't press it too hard otherwise you'll
dry out the tuna
now these are water chestnuts just slice
them
nice and thin you can buy them anywhere
any supermarket
chestnuts in fresh ginger
get rid of that rough skin on the
outside
by grating the ginger you get to get all
that really nice
sort of juice in
take your spring onions and just slice
on an angle i like the texture of the
water chestnut
with a spring onion we'll touch of fresh
coriander
lovely next remove the seeds from a
chili to reduce its heat without losing
any flavor
and finely chop chilies
in kaffir lime leaves roll them up
nice and tight run your knife down the
center
once and just chop
and that makes the fish cake nice and
fragrant
such of salt a touch of pepper
fish sauce just lightly season
the tuna to bind all those wonderful
ingredients
two whole eggs
and give that a nice little whisk
and then add your eggs
get your hands in there and start mixing
get the mixture roll it and hand the
hand
into the palm pat them down nicely
to cook add a little ground oil to a hot
pan
at the face of a clock i'm going to go
from 12 all the way around
first one in these fish cakes only take
a few minutes to cook
so keeping track of the order they go in
the pan means you know which one to turn
first
give the pad a nice gentle little shake
make sure that nothing's sticking to the
bottom
spatula two fingers on top turn them
over
beautiful that crackling noise is
something you always want because
the tune's already cooked so we just
lightly frying them we get a nice
crisp outside and gently take them out
smell incredible
let them sit there we're gonna make a
really nice delicious simple dipping
sauce
start off a little pinch of sugar fish
sauce
two tablespoons that gives it the
saltiness
one tablespoon of rice wine vinegar
and some fresh lime juice squeeze all
that lime in there
your fresh coriander lots of coriander
and then give that
a little mix and then you have
the most amazing spicy tuna fish cakes
who would have thought
something as delicious as that can come
out of a can a simple supper in minutes
that's so mouth-wateringly easy and
delicious
you're guaranteed to cook it again and
again
you